right I read somewhere uh that you're
that your only fans is making a million
a month is that accurate or no I think
my quote was that in general I make like
around a million a month okay yeah so it
was like it's funny because I feel like
every I've never really like said
anything about how much money I make and
I wanted to say it on this one it was
like a business podcast right and I just
wanted to throw that number out there
and it's not like we are actually like
making that every month or it's like
obviously there's a lot of expenses a
lot of things that go into [ __ ] in
general like anybody could tell you that
their business is not the net amount
that they bring in that month or
whatever yeah and it's it's shocking how
[ __ ] little remains after all the
overhead and attacks acts of Jesus
Christ yeah welcome to paying 50 in
taxes yeah man it's a whole thing
there's a lot of girls making money on
only fans that weren't making money
before and it's like dude what about all
these chicks that are like making a [ __ ]
load of money like are they paying taxes
like like nobody's telling them to like
well hopefully if I are because for sure
your only Finn's revenue is being
reported very transparently to the
government once you transfer it into
your bank account yeah but yeah like I
mean the only reason I wanted to say
that is because you know in my world the
rap world it's like rappers feel totally
fine telling you hey I made 200 000 for
playing a show last night or I made 50
000 for doing a walk through or I just
dropped this album and I made a million
bucks whatever and it's like as a media
person you're kind of expected to never
do that and the reality is is that I
kind of like look at the up and coming
generation of YouTubers and I want to
like Inspire them or at least let them
know what's possible so I I kind of like
felt like airing that number out and I
just picked that number to just give
like a sort of oversimplification but
just because I want these kids who do
YouTube videos and [ __ ] to know that
it's like yo if you're making five grand
a month right now I mean there's
possibility like I was in that position
too and I grounded my ass off and built
my business into something way crazier
you know yeah for sure yeah I heard you
guys uh when I went in there talking
about Steve will do it and you know
getting canceled on YouTube but yeah
his overhead doesn't stop you know and
so if part of his YouTube he's not
making that much money anymore right I
mean the dynamic with Steve will do it
that's so fascinating to me is that here
he's throwing around so much money but
that's his stick you know that like
outside of throwing around so much money
like what content is he gonna be really
putting out so he got kind of like
I I almost think trapped in that
lifestyle of throwing around money
because that's what sort of
you know his career is but the thing
with him is that he never made any money
on YouTube ads so that was never a
concern in the first place it's all
about merch and then sponsors like
primarily the [ __ ] gambling sponsors
I think is like a huge percentage of his
income and him not having a YouTube
channel really shouldn't totally change
that because you still have Instagram
Tick Tock whatever like he could still
make the same content he was making and
just put it on Tick Tock and Facebook
and stuff obviously that's going to be a
compromise because it sucks to lose your
5 million subscribers or whatever but
like I really think that if he just like
dedicates himself that he'll be able to
make it so that him having a YouTube
channel doesn't really matter but he's
gonna definitely have to be creative and
yeah I mean like I've always felt like
that watching all these people give away
so much money it's like it is inspiring
and it's heartwarming and stuff but then
at the same time you're like
is this work in the long run to make a
YouTube video that you make 10 grand on
and you're spending 100 Grand in the
video like me just as like a person who
was broke not that long ago I'm just
like it just doesn't make me feel
comfortable right me too and um I think
that there's different approaches to it
like I look at at David dobrik and the
way that he throws around a lot I think
David dobrik is highly strategic you
know and like every time David dobrik
gives away a car I feel like it's
actually a sponsor giving away the car I
think more often than not yeah yeah so I
just think that David dobrik is uh
considerably more Savvy and uh and you
know not to say that I mean I just don't
know if Steve will do it's just a
[ __ ] mystery man he's so fascinating
and I I love the guy
I've always been worried about him as
long as I've known him just because you
have been around long enough and me to a
certain extent too or you've seen so
many people make 10 million dollars and
then [ __ ] up 10 million dollars so it's
like but but younger people they see
somebody making a million bucks a month
or whatever and they're like oh he's
rich and he's gonna be rich forever
right we we know how easy it is to [ __ ]
that up I mean I haven't really done it
but like I've seen other people do it
and I know what it looks like so that's
why I'm so thankful that I managed to
like grind my ass off through my 20s and
early 30s and then only started to see
success once I already had like eaten
[ __ ] so many times and had the world
just [ __ ] spit in my face so many
times so that by the time I finally
started getting to it
yeah I was cautious you know right and
like we were saying on your podcast
about just not feeling the need to be uh
extravagant in your lifestyle you know
like I think that clip was awesome but
not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what I've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions which
is out September 27th and if you
pre-order it right now you can get the
autographed copy so get on it man
pre-order my book it's not gonna waste
your time because I'm proven dude New
York Times bestseller my first book's
Five star rated on Amazon and I have no
doubt this one will be too so get the
autograph copy right now by pre-ordering
it at stevo.com
yeah dude